[MUSIC]
MICHAEL HECHT: We knew that in
addition to the Dalai Lama's
visit, there would be monks
coming by ahead of time
doing a sand mandala, which
is a piece of artwork that
exemplifies this concept
of non-permanence
and non-attachment.
So we decided that one way to
introduce the students to some
of these central
concepts in Buddhism
would be to have then do a
sand mandala on their own.
And so we coupled
this with the dinners
that we have of my
house for the freshman.
And so the students
worked on sand paintings
of Forbes class
of 2018, which is
something that's central to
their experience, something
that they might
become attached to,
but something that is,
after all, impermanent.
NATASHA TURKMANI:
I kind of viewed it
as a beautiful project in a way.
That we're all building this
sense of community together.
That the bond that we created
through making this project
isn't shown through
the sand, but it's
shown through our efforts.
DUC NGUYEN: A Geshe, which is
high ranking Tibetan monk came
to visit Forbes to give a
discussion about the Dalai
Lama's visit and also about
the tenets of Tibetan Buddhism
and to also let him see the sand
paintings that the freshman did
during the Zee Dinners.
DAVID HOYOS: He spoke a little
bit about the sand mandalas
and their purpose which
really fascinated me.
Because he explained
how these monks,
they worked so hard,
day in and day out,
building these sand mandalas.
And they get attached
to them but part
of their responsibility is
to detach themselves from it.
They have to have that
willpower to destroy the sand
mandala they worked
so hard to make.
That was kind of a
reminder that they
must be detached the world.
And he was saying that this
ties into a Buddhist principle
where pain or suffering,
the root of that is desire
or it is attachment.
So if you can relinquish
all attachment
you reduce a lot of suffering.